en faire le point faible surtout ça avec
joanie fontaine elle est économiste
principal chez jlr merci d'être là
madame fontaine
ce sont des gros chiffre clairement tous
ces rebonds
on a une baisse historique en avril
c'est vrai rebond considérable par la
suite comment on expliquer ce que c'est
le retour du balancier
en fait c'est les gens finalement qui
ont reporté leurs achats
on commence en avril mais on a eu des
fortes baisses et on eu une vie des -60
pour ça et là les gens finalement dû à
l'arrêt on peut moins visités c'était
plus compliqué donc ça la limite et
beaucoup d'acheteurs dans l'or dans
leurs mouvements
donc on voit le retour de certains des
acheteurs le finalement en juin passe
pour rappeler l'oeil et les
déménagements je vois déjà qui avait pas
que nous les leur bail et qui le
cherchait une propriété pendant un bout
d'os ont pas pu visiter le facilement de
propriété donc on se retrouve avec un
gros bassin d'acheteurs en juin qui
était un peu pressés d'acheter dans
certains cas donc à un mode rattrapage
les augmentations qu'on observe pour le
mois de juin c'est pas soutenable ça
sera pas ça la réalité immobilière des
prochains mois non c'est vraiment un
mode rattrapage vont parler le de plus
de 30% le cd des alimentations qu'on
voit à peu près jamais on le but étant
donné les circonstances des deux
derniers mois mais on s'attend
éventuellement que la demande va être
moins forte
la pandémie a quand même une des
conséquences économiques sur plusieurs
ménages dont cameron demandent qui est
un petit peu moins forte mais on risque
de le voir un petit peu plus le rendu à
l'automne bon on sait qu'un peu les
chiffres de l'immobilier il ya une
tendance très claire à tout le moins
pour la grande région de montréal
lille en tant que tel semble pas avoir
accéléré le rythme des transactions mais
sa poussée en banlieue entre autres bon
on a des chiffres le vaudreuil soulanges
44% la rive-nord
saint-jean-sur-richelieu presque 40%
qu'est ce qui se passe mais on en sait
un certain déplacement finalement de la
demande des gens qui devaient au lieu
d'avoir un petit condo peut-être moi je
peux me permettre une plus grosse maison
sur la rue sur nous la rive nord où peu
importe en banlieue on essaie de la
cambrousse à madame fontaine
il ya une partie qui peut s'expliquer
effectivement parce que les gens pensent
qu'ils vont faire travailler à la maison
à long terme donc de le plus d espace et
peuvent se paie
mais finalement de s'éloigner parce
qu'ils ont moins besoin d'aller en ville
faut aussi voir le en termes de
transactions que beaucoup des
transactions mais si on parle du
centre-ville de moi qui étais fait aussi
part des investisseurs qui voulait par
exemple mettre la propriété en location
court terme ou des investisseurs qui
veulent louer à des étudiants donc cette
clientèle n'est peut-être pas au rendez
vous dans le centre de royan donc ça
fait aussi diminuer le nombre de
transactions donc appétit accru pour les
banlieues est ce que ça va même plus
loin la campagne les chalets résidence
secondaire à ce qu'il ya de la demande
accrue pour ça on a l'impression que oui
à tout le moins
mais si on regarde les chiffres
provinciaux on a dit aux deux
transactions qui sont plus élevés par
exemple que justement le sur l'île de
montréal
donc on constate quand même qu'un
intérêt pour les régions peut-être un
peu plus éloignés pour les centres de
villégiature on veut on veut parfois les
chalets ya un intérêt pour ce titre de
propriété longtemps mais on veut plus en
vacances peut-être qu'on pourrait avoir
un chalet plutôt il ya des gens qui
m'ont vraiment ménagé possiblement dans
leur chalet plus à long terme
donc oui un intérêt pour pour ces
régions là mêmes dans les centres
urbains on a l'impression que ça change
un peu le type d'habitation qui est
recherché à une plus forte augmentation
pour le nombre de transactions
concernant les maisons les unifamiliales
que pour les condos par exemple en fait
c'est que on peut se permettre
si on peut travailler à domicile de
s'éloigner un peu du santé has no more
on peut se permettre souvent plus grand
donc on peut se permettre une maison
plutôt qu'un condo par exemple alors
qu'au centre-ville n'avaient pas
nécessairement les moyens de payer la
maison le s1 temporaire selon vous cet
intérêt pour plus grand plus loin je
pense qu'il ya une vague un peu le au
début est-ce que ça va se perpétuer je
pense que le travail de monsieur quand
même là pour rester donc il va avoir une
certaine incidence
par contre le camp quand la pandémie
burgos terminé il va voir un retour
quand même des investisseurs au
centre-ville il va avoir un trou de
certaines personnes qui aiment la
dynamique aussi du centre ville
mais c'est sûr que l'on a un effet
pandémie mais les faits le travail à la
maison risque quand même perdurer le à
travers les années bon on a déjà des
prix qui sont en forte augmentation
comparativement à l'an dernier
lorsque j'entends c'est que ça pourrait
augmenter encore on pourrait encore se
retrouver encore plus avec la surenchère
parce qu'il y en a en ce moment où le
marché de vendeurs madame fontaine on
est encore un marché de vendeurs mais ça
risque de changer le avec les mois à
venir
parce que ce qui se passe présentement
c'est que très peu d'eau flow 9 une
hausse quand même des mises en marché
mais très peu d'offres encore sur le
marché parce que les gens ont reporté
une verte leurs propriétés en vente mais
en septembre octobre à l'automne à les
allégements hypothécaires vont se
terminer pour plusieurs il ya plusieurs
ménages qui seront pas nécessairement
envie de continuer de payer leur
hypothèque un clan des difficultés
financières parce que c'est pas tout le
monde que lors retrouver son emploi
rendu à l'automne donc l'on s'attend ce
qui est des maisons qu'ils reviennent
beaucoup plus sur le marché et des gens
qui soient quand même très vendeur dans
certains cols presse que dans ces
circonstances là on va se terminer là tu
es ce que les prix vont continuer
d'augmenter au la schl qui disait qu'on
allait plutôt atteindre un creux l'an
prochain
on s'attend à ce que les autres qu'on
voit présentement le soient temporaires
on a quand même ce qu'on appelle un
acquis de croissance le cliché que le
fait que des hausses par le passé mais
les prix sont élevés donc même si
dignité un peu par rapport à l'année
dernière on peut voir une certaine
hausse mais on s'attend à ce que sa
recule un peu là dans la fin 2020 début
2000 21
ouais c'est un marché très chaud ça et
c'est clair merci beaucoup pour vos
explications madame fontaine
merci à vous